oh yes here we are after Friday games oh
we need to go back to their they are ok
and we're acts right behind us is the
building 44 arcade here at in beautiful
building 44 in Mountain View Manny and
I'm Dan Galpin and once again with me is
our intrepid world traveler kokhim I'm
back it's been a while folks well how
are you excellent and we've got a great
set of games here today for us to look
at it includes the gravity vending block
backing breakout game that is spaced out
light the pin toppling transposition of
shuffleboard bowling in poker that is
Tenten shuffle jump one and the wannabe
lost cat creation no Esme ouch that's
hot Sun right now you shut me out yeah
Jimmy ouch okay so me all which is an
interesting take on a multi-character
platform game that combines aspects of
lemmings and then snappy dragon to the
sequel to the original stampy dragons
where you get to be a cute dragon and
you get the throw fireballs at all your
enemies that's right now it's all those
pesky garden gnomes yes it's almost a
physics game but not quite mm-hmm
alright so let's uh let's let's go on to
our first game which is going to be
spaced out light I think the viewers
want to know what connect beer you guys
are drinking oh very good point good
point so we are drinking today today the
danica Brewing Company Liberty a lesson
hold it up so you all can see it it's
really nice i'm a huge fan of anger in
general um they are up in san francisco
and you can go and take a tour of the
brewery it's really fun I've never done
it but I know a lot of people who have
given really really good looking back on
it so let's take a quick look at spaced
out the listing for space out light and
normally we always review the pay
version here on the Friday review which
often gives the best experience with
viewers but also guarantees that are and
also guarantees a result forgets one
sale oh we need to buy it afterwards
yeah I haven't done it yet but we're
lazy today so here's a light version
that was actually nominated
and you know I this I I wanted to say
this feature graphic contains a really
good set of elements it makes it clear
what sort of game we're talking about
you know the space out graphic it's
always a good size right very legible if
the game is featuring it could be a
little bit more polished looking and I
think that perhaps that the effect
behind spaced out might be a little bit
much right if it's all of our guidelines
ya know for sure I mean if you think
about like this is the first graphic if
your game ever does get featured that
gets seen on your mobile phone so you
have to think about the screen size as
well and so it's always important to
focus on the most important elements
which is the title and also what your
game is about so it actually do hope it
would actually include a little bit more
of the 3d depth because the actual game
is in 3d and you know it's kind of
strange that I seeing like a 2d 8-bit
version game so I actually was not
expecting the game that i was playing
from the feature graphic that's true
that's true they could go a little
further the other thing I was gonna say
is I love the fact the icon is not a
rounded rectangle that's that's always
really really nice yes see I you know I
actually meant it when I see a whole
bunch of round two rectangles I just I
have a harder time recognizing what the
different things are this makes it very
very clear you know the daikon is really
distinct it's got a distinct shape
really like it when people take
advantage of the fact that we don't
require that everything looked the same
all right so the game itself involves
changing gravity around we can now
switch to the view of the game itself
and this is going to be challenging
because we actually in Italy it's have
happily without
all right he's doing this one-handed
it's pretty awesome yeah this is a first
of all of you actually align the screens
you can prevent me starting the games
way this and this list levels actually
should mean all the news you can see
it's telling me that gravity the higher
levels actually get allow you to die
this level is just really a tutorial
logic kind of screams I mean that's why
I'm showing up i'm actually tablet
upside down here yeah and you notice
that's he's actually playing the game so
yeah just one one of the power of this
firepower pick it up we're lose 85 frank
cyanide one of the glorious things that
is my gravy life but it's really not
been spun around like this
this is an explosion one this power one
of my my parents are really really well
done
I know there is there is a turn to the
ark itself the textures could be on the
box right there the same sort of like
yeah I mean there's something it's very
cool right about them yeah I thought me
my feelings right sort of like I want to
see kind of cool design come on like got
random pieces of marble stuff like that
yeah also like it's the color scheme
right like the problem with space these
backgrounds at all that's very dark and
so I mean I can imagine if I'm playing
this in a very brightly lit area there's
probably be hard for me to see where go
hang a little bit in the game just get
hard very very quickly right there just
this level here it's very very easy to
die trying to hold this together hope
everyone right you see because if you
because the way that you die is if you
actually jump out of this blockade
Miriam so one of the fun car out Maggie
legends
now I'll see if I can do this about
dying all right this is the other side
suspect next get out of the game for you
all
there are two balls it's truly dan is it
is a big gamer in like this should be
easy right yes actually I think this
game is easy I really enjoyed and ya
know I mean says selfish great job yes I
mean I really have to congratulate and
the game is really really fun great did
you can play it so great twist on break
out absolutely now some other things I
always like to know one we've got menu
p.m. you're not targeting menu anymore
you know and it makes a change of do
anything and relax one thing that
happens is for a game like this is using
native code of the active terminal on
prey of compatibility packs basically
make sure that
that slows performance allowed through
their car
just to keep you
all right I think I sage anywhere you
want to stand I don't know what I mean I
always still like love to check my
favorite the back button it looks like
the back button back superb news expert
before brightly yet no that was which is
good thanks guys make you feel like
people are watching show yeah also we
are we're playing without sound but I
correctly alright let's go to the next
game what do we play next sorry alone
but alex is going to beat a pin shuffle
which guy is is is we're going to go
into a landscape sorry portrait boat
game here eventually but let's let's
talk a little bit about their feature
graphic now this feature graphic has
tenth and shuffle appearing very very
small yeah and it honestly honestly this
is one of those times where in the one
you have in the game in terms of icon is
nice but in this it's just a very very
tiny part of the scene that things that
I love the rest of it other than the
title which I have change up i think i
would just get rid of the 10 pin shuffle
shuffle board look and just move those
those two pieces of text out make them
larger right it would look much better
it's also just to a graphic design
perspective it really does feel just
squashed up there in the middle when
you're on the landscape screen like like
like the like the view we provided a
geographic when you're looking at at on
the device itself it looks okay because
it's a note in portrait mode this is a
forest portrait mode game right but you
do get a very good idea of what the game
is going to be it's going to be
combination of shuffleboard and bowling
and also poker oh sorry yeah they've
like mixed up a different lot of
different genres you this is a whole
gaming mash right now it's which is and
I first started playing I'm like I mean
the only thing really kind of sucks
about the gables good to actually move
on to the game screen here is it you
could actually kick butt on the bowling
and shuffleboard so right but they can
still knock in the poker site amazon the
poker siding there's and it's not just
betting or anything like that we might
actually been kind of made it mid even
more interesting so temptin poker is the
only game that's actually active in the
on is the indian the free version i lock
this which i really should have done god
you know i'm told ya I all this income
tour yeah
all those locks now I'm actually curious
i was gonna actually get the premium
version of it I know I intended to it's
okay i'm gonna attempt to play the
sideways yeah oh yeah actually I a week
we can actually will rotate it will be
rotated here we are and we lose it here
are one two three alright it's much much
easier to play okay and i actually had
set up i think to play with a component
i like it so badly um you tab let you
take over so that that would set the
controls
as well as I'm ready to get my butt kick
right now I think a protein start but
actually much on your accuracy
xray that place liable so cranky and so
but it all in all seriousness my gosh I
realized a lot of times how I
right
straight shot the presentation is really
really nice I love the little reflective
effect on the surface you know that it's
a very nicely done there's a lot of
really good done really well done sound
effects as well yeah we're not hearing
um and yeah like the gestures are really
great on this games absolutely and it's
really really nice like when you get up
when you get a spare it does it does
things like has it has a crowd that
you've been here that booths when you
get a split this is a really really well
done game yeah you know again this is
another game that you can see the best
digital menu on the bottom of but as far
as i can tell inhales down correctly
this is right everything south korea
more purpley when I remembered yeah I
see look you want a pretty or quit no I
don't want to quit Thank pretty well I
tried it again does it does it exam yeah
just do anything so that right that no
yeah better self they should dismiss it
yeah you know rather than have it dude
rather ever do nothing or you know
potentially take you back to me ok I'd
like dismissing because it's really
clearly a dialogue sad some great our QA
team would actually say hey you should
make it do something because the back
you should always do something right and
so but other than that you know the game
the game works well in terms of in terms
of tablet presentation it's pretty good
too i think that there might it might be
that the gestures are a little bit of
anger on tablet then they might need to
be in life you might be fun to play with
that mm-hmm in terms of in terms of how
you move position and actually shoot i'm
not sure how much the developer did with
that but I thought was my feeling as I i
had to gesture a little longer right i
thought i should have to in order to
actually make it go but also varies
right because i play this on my Nexus 7
and it seems to me like you know the
sensitivity on that was a little bit
different than what a transformer is so
I mean if you give if you give the user
some sort of way to like me like oh like
maybe I just want to flick a little bit
traces like like substituting controls
have been nice yeah i think you know i
think the way to do this news is to
build an initial sensitivity based upon
the density of the screen in hand and
and maybe not in this case not even the
density to scream but actually right on
the distance that the user actually is
having to swipe you know so that's
that's something to think about in terms
in terms of improving it I still thought
it was pretty darn yeah it was pretty
good i mean like it's very high quality
once you got used to it figured out oh
what's going on yeah I have no I have no
qualms recommending this game two
friends you know it's fun I know there
are a couple of little tiny issues in
terms of presentation that can be helped
on the tablet but you know honestly not
without without being nitpicky i would
say it looks really really solid okay
and so yeah great job there on 10 pin
shuffle will go on to our next title man
let's title i know i know you have to
end your game cuz you yeah i know i'm
actually doing pretty well it was this
is like not normal for me i'm actually
was pretty bad see what I'm so sorry
have you see by the way what's going on
in the game is that as you as you play
the game you actually get a better and
better poker hand and you get your
billet e to swap out cards so that is so
seeks you can say which one you want to
I don't know I don't want to lose my
pears your parents ought to take out the
99 I mean that's you know it's it's a
big guy I haven't tried counting cards
with this to see how accurate it is I
was sort of curious to see I was
thinking about that too but yeah I
assume it's from a single back but you
know I don't know oh well we'll see
we're almost done with here that we got
sometimes lets Fitz Fitz see let's see
how we gonna do so all of you exactly so
by the way I have never won a game of
this in poker it is nice tricks they
asked cuz some half the computer has
always gotten a better poem I really
don't get that at all let's let's get
rid of a the jack in the King here and
we keep our ace high and then draw let's
go for it I should have just gotten a
man that sometimes I'm just like not
yeah as I said you don't you know it's
hard it's hard to tell exactly what's
going on because you can't tell with the
computer yeah I find the computer
they've done the computer nicely so that
if you are really really sucking at the
shuffleboard part of the game the
computer does really really badly so the
one thing the one thing that I kind of
am a little like what's not take out is
if you look in the upper right corner it
does say available on the App Store and
so and that's all this is a default ad
when an ad isn't showing up come on
guys right I don't have one of them
devices do right it's an android game
now alright so let's list you got one
more shot want to get rid of that one
and such a definitely i just i think
that at this point you'd want to keep
the thing i would say already they go
for GAD go for it again yeah look at the
head this amy alright wise it's not
anything to find out what happens
between this fancy i will holla to what
one thing it is kind of frustrating is I
do not also the end of the bowling game
if it doesn't actually if you end up
getting a strike it does right extra it
does yeah i was gonna be really mad if i
had a better full house yeah exactly
alright we finally won alright so that's
uh I oh no no no no it's not it's not
playing the new opponents right so I
guess I guess I end up getting more on
more challenging opponents as well so
again thumbs up clever mash up a bunch
of stuff I just as mashup exist does
anyone know as I don't even know that's
the first time I saw mash up like this I
was like poker and shuffleboard yeah and
bullying I really I really wanna know
you know so so so did you find out a
game post a link and i'd be interested a
gigantic viewers out there know the
answer to this you know let us know and
it actually that would be a very
interesting show we should do a mashup
genre mashup show alright so let's go on
to our next game yeah so well i'll let
you i'll let you up move the tablet co
and I'll control the the slide decks or
our next game is going to be me out Shh
and me ouch is you kind of an
interesting game because I wasn't sure I
wasn't really sure i saw the feature
graphic I'm like what is this game
interesting yeah I mean it is a very
bold feature graphic though so give the
developer whoever designed that much
it's definitely I good
attention-grabbing let's put so switch
over to here right there's has like whoa
transition so yes you can tell that you
and didn't make this day oh so yeah
actually this this is a great feature
graphic in term
of making sure the text is forward it
does not tell me anything about the game
sometimes it's a good thing sometimes I
Melanie yeah you know doesn't it doesn't
necessarily have to one of things is
really interesting had a developer who
got there at featured recently and they
double the number of installs just
fighting a more attractive feature
graphic and they actually went and they
did the first original feature graphic
was just a blow-up version of their logo
and they ended up replacing it with this
beautiful artwork and imagery actually
dutiful imagery in this right with with
a smaller with a slightly smaller
version of their load with it but it
just looked pro well yeah I mean it was
the app dwell abul so what it was a
basically a vacation rental app and
originally it was just basically this
garish bright orange background with
their logo and so if you can imagine
you're like what is this app it doesn't
tell me anything that it does but that's
all gonna be this beautiful house that
you that you could rent right along with
12 Oh Land Boom all of a sudden it's
double install love's labour's as well
so you know I so these feature graphics
really are important like I don't know
how many more times we have to emphasize
this this is great I I think that I
honestly don't know if I would represent
this game any other way yeah it's pretty
it's pretty reasonable it's hard to go
what's going on in this game right until
you play but luckily they have like a
free version for everyone to try so it
gives everyone a chance to try it sounds
absolutely alright so let's go into the
actual gameplay itself will switch over
to our game place liar ah ok rotate the
time I had a rotate it back hit it back
because this is it may be actually like
leaving this in the key dockets because
it makes it easy when we have to rotate
it so we don't otherwise otherwise it's
kind of a challenge yeah yeah yeah so
all right Tala la I didn't play this one
as much as some of the other games but
we'll just go to the first level because
it's just easy yes it is just to say
what's going on yo you don't get that
you don't get the humans trying to grab
the cat through the windows right that
happened in the second level which was
kind of crazy so basically you're
essentially cat and all you do is let
you actually are a cat I don't even
think it's essential yeah but you're
essentially trying to get all these I
guess meow cat food and then go to the
exit right it's a missing cat sign right
you're trying to get rid of the missing
cat side so that you can
and because obviously they enjoy your
freedom you know your freedoms the
gradual is you're like this this not
stray cat your cat he was trying to be
found by its owner and you're
desperately trying to avoid being found
by your owner which is kind of weird
actually unless you're Dylan less maybe
what you are as you are no it's a
missing cat sign so it is a missing cat
sighs so you're a cat that decided to
escape from its order because you don't
like cat ladies so good that is that
does seem to be actually right after the
case you are owned by crazy cat your own
by crazy cat lady and you're trying to
escape for your freedom and so so so the
game does get harder in the second level
and there's a lot more elements you also
are sort of a kind of a cat I would
describe him is being sort of using the
you're sort of the angry cat meta meta
metaphor here where you actually are
kind of a giant kitty slingshot right
you actually kind of pull the tail on
your cat back in order to use launcher
cap right word probably for for reasons
of animal abuse they don't actually show
this which is probably good but it is a
little the controls are a little weird
that's not really obvious what you're
doing like wow am i pulling back on the
cat to make yeah wasn't I wasn't really
sure about that it took me a while to
figure out what I even like the
objective to I think a lot of it I
didn't realize oh I was that missing cat
yeah exactly exactly so anyways we'll
just try to get out of here I didn't I
didn't do well this level but at least I
avoided the crazy right you're trying to
get me and the animal control right but
but that's that's basically the game
sure it they've add more elements as you
go farther into the game frame as I said
he didn't it didn't strike me as a game
that i really had to play from an art
style perspective it's it's somewhat
consistent it's a little you know it
does it definitely has that i drew this
in adobe all right i'm kind of look to
it but it doesn't and it's fine i mean i
think i think it's you know it from one
I from what I saw it seems like a
reasonably a reasonably clever game but
you know it did kind of strategies sort
of an odd game and I get
I really wanted to get and play this
game deeper that I actually right kind
of strange things about this game in
terms of like the juxtaposition of
different elements you do have this sort
of the numbers have a really really
different fields that's right we're in a
couple of other things that might be
worth playing with her to keep this
you've got this really cool hand Ron
style already yeah well I think a lot of
is just like try to educate your player
on like what all these different
elements are right like what's actually
bad like I didn't even realize the
lighted yellow windows is actually the
crazy cat lady can come out and it took
me 2 i'll be like oh I was not supposed
to do that like it doesn't give you an
indication of whether you like not like
failure per se but you did something
wrong like I had no idea I was like oh
animal pest control oh yeah that's
actually I don't want to get caught by
that right or oh like these antennas
like these satellite dishes oh I can
bounce off of them you just have no idea
unless you experiment that's all I mean
that could be a good thing but you want
to make sure that I mean this is only
the third or fourth level right so I
mean you have to think about like your
who your audiences in terms of like
these types of arcade action games you
just want to make sure hey like ouch
yeah so um so one of the things that's
interesting about this game that I
always say is it is actually I want more
frames of animation actually was
especially in the cat because I you know
there's some but I think that's actually
what one of the things that that would
make the game really just feel that much
better when you have the cat and the cat
is the main character just a couple of
additional frames would look really
really good so that way if there is any
like little polished i would add to the
game you know everything else is pretty
much just stylistically worked all right
about here now I will say you know one
thing I'm really happy to see is this
game actually is targeting a recent SDK
we don't see a vegetable menu mm-hmm um
in terms in terms of back key support
you know yeah does exactly the wrong
thing right it doesn't bring up a menu
an actual menu button it just brings up
do you want to exit so exactly but at
least it's something I mean this is
progress I mean before we had a lot of
games I didn't have anything but that
game is also coming so
I wasn't sure sure I wasn't a game that
really engaged me like you know spaced
out really engaged me 10 pin shuffle
really engage me ouch ouch was fun I
think I would probably recommend it to
someone it seems like it was targeted at
someone younger than you at the same
time it also seemed really really
challenging like I cried have wondered
whether an eight-year like in world one
number three was it was pretty pretty
hard until I figured out yeah somebody
my feeling is it's sort of this strange
combination of a game that seems to be
targeted kids but seems very difficult
for kids right a navy maybe there is
some balance it can be struck better all
right a great art style at A+ grade art
style I like I like the design the
graphics oh but definitely a lot to me
apprised now we're gonna we're going to
eventually move to a landscape game all
right all right and this game is so me
all he said say Sammy all Samuel yes
Samuel yeah so I wasn't quite sure how
it was pronounced but that's a you know
if I believe co in this case and yeah
and this is actually kind of straight so
I see this feature graphic I have no
idea what to expect i'm suing the samuel
is actually probably what those little
lemming like creatures are yeah you know
so no again london's were green hair
with you know this is purple hair so
they're definitely not living right and
i would say this is a lot a lot of
things about this game first of all we
can actually look at their future so the
piece of grab you here actually at least
has the text fortune um it's big it's
flashing eye catching we have another
rounded-corners icon for no apparent
especially when you've got something at
this dynamic and catch and eye-catching
as the actual so me all hair itself it
just sticks out in all directions you
know why not make that part of your icon
part of that look you know so i think i
think we missed out there's a missed
opportunity yeah you can definitely do
background transparent image and just
stick out there that's that probably
fine absolutely so let's but let's
actually look at the game itself so
hopefully we actually have this so we
can actually play it we can't actually
play now search some some things you may
not notice at home everything is real
you really low res right okay I mean in
this game like exceptionally
exceptionally low res and it is a
hand-drawn art style but when you see
hand-drawn art it's so much nicer when
you actually get to see it at at a
resolution close to what the tablet is
playing on it just feels like okay this
was made a long time ago right and it's
not made a long time ago in that oh cool
its retro it's made a long time ago in
as in someone didn't is about EFT he
lived in SD land is that it was made for
a device you know that had a much lower
resolution than this and other other
notes we've got lots of icons all over
this screen we have individual icons for
a whole bunch of things i'm actually at
least glad that it's not trying to get
me to click on them but you know I
always I always feel like if you're
going to do an android game having a
standard Android share icon in addition
to all those at least if not it being
the only thing there is really nice
because right now if I wanted to post my
google plus account I can't do it if I
want to send email that contain similar
information I can't do it if I wanted to
share stuff something perhaps from the
web store to someone I can't from the
from the app from the Google Play Store
I can't do it so there's a lot of things
here I if I wanted to rate the game
there might be a way to do this I have
no idea how I might do this now this
from from inside the screen there's a
lot of things that are here that may or
may not be useful and yet a bunch of
things that are that are definitely
important like please rate the game is
not here so just just some little
thoughts here or if it is there I can't
possibly I what it is and again we kind
of considered this we can go back to
this very very low res kind of hand
hand-drawn art style cute but the game
is really inventive and I think that's
actually what's kind of exciting about
it is um let's go to one of the levels
that's ready yeah again no and again
like it's like it's like interesting
yeah yeah well you know it's it's it's
definitely our work that I that feels
like the stuff that I would draw if I
were mean it could be on purpose I just
wish it was in higher definition yeah
yeah I get it you know it's it's it's
hard to say when you're looking whenever
you're looking at a title like this
you're like well was this intended
it is you're supposed to have her feel
so very cool things about this game so
this is actually a multi a multiplayer a
platform game where I've got to get
these guys to safety and get them onto
the rocket okay obviously very very
straightforward to do in that level but
it gets tricky because sometimes what
you have to do is actually group them
together and so you can actually
sometimes drop them into place and have
to squash them into one indoor level and
there are puzzles to solve or so half of
them go one place and have them go the
other way and you get you control them
all is this block so a lot of times it's
figuring out how to split them up and
still control and etc etc there's a lot
of really interesting puzzles there's a
lot going for this game I you know I
kind of want I just want a presentation
that's just a little that says to users
like yes this game really had a lot of
thought put it right is probably the
Game Boy element is probably it's very
it's very interesting I think it's very
unique and yes oh yeah i'd like i'd like
to see the game do more right you know
one other thing to know that this game
is and is is also not only as a game
targeting an ancient sdk version but
it's actually not targeting all screens
so we have the zoom controls on it and
you knows and it might actually look
better honestly zoom zoom in from this
particular case although you know it's
pretty much a going to be it's going to
look very similar and there are a few
assets here that are higher resolution
than others so you know that might be
something worth worth noting um in terms
of back key support it is doing like
it's doing what it's supposed to that's
like this plz rate holy God be better if
that was a link right it is a link and I
couldn't tell ya um but any case oh
that's so me all I and the final game
that we're going to look at today is
snappy dragons too snappy dragons too
and savvy dragons too is is a beautiful
looking game extension studios did a
fabulous job on it is again a sequel to
to the to the original game and we're
once again find a lite version if you
nominate the lite version there's a
chance that we'll play the lite version
if you want us to actually you know use
the premium version please nominate the
premium version will do it don't don't
make your premium version like $10,000
the one day we
we go to that but you know in all
seriousness I you know we don't probably
won't review it well I think it's
actually the match Miz like 99 ok Google
Play but any case uh feature graphic
wise really cool I'm not really sure if
I would have used the the kind of the
transition between the yellow to red
it's really hard to see against the
light yeah background you can't really
tell you're on the website but we have
that we have the beautiful advantage
that we're actually looking at the
screen right now at a very small screen
like I couldn't possibly read the text
in the review itself from where we're
looking but the size of the review of
the two of the graphic they were looking
at right now is not that far off from
this size on a phone or tablet and I
just it looks like can't see anything
like I can't read it yeah it looks like
p drag to I can read the two so a little
bit more contrast would actually help
quite a bit and this is one of those
times where a really a subtle drop
shadow would help a little bit more
there might be one if there is one it's
really subtle right here no no a little
one yeah I mean we can read it we can
read it when we're looking at a closer
screen so I'm like so that I mean really
the biggest thing is just think about
like you know when you think about
designing your feature graphic always
think about your color schemes what
you're using and a lot of that stuff I
mean like there's always a son a lot of
cool color science thing but yeah come
on hunter isn't the composition is great
oh yeah this is great you know honestly
if they just switch that all to read
letters it probably would have been fine
it would have popped we have popped a
lot more or orange like blue a blue and
orange are like complementary so yeah
they're gonna stand out to contrast the
other thing is you know no rounded
rectangle needed on this guy you're kind
of you're already pushing the boundaries
on it I always say just get rid of it it
looks it looks it looks cool enough
without it we don't need it and yeah
that's my that would be Mike my take on
that so let's go to the actual game
itself yeah sure game stuff oh I wanted
to show people what I didn't like about
the game start up so let's restart the
yeah we're going to restart the game so
we sow yeah um mostly because this is a
this is a slight pet peeve of mine but
mostly all right if this is the first
screen so it's anybody 3 have you played
the game before yes so like if you look
at this from first glance think about a
user I looked at this I was like well is
this an ad am I supposed to click on
something or is this just another screen
it's actually very hard to tell and it
wasn't until I started touching a screen
that I realized oh I was
to touch it yeah I'm ready to start
that's a really really good point I
think it's one of those things where as
an interstitial where it's really clear
that it's interstitial this is cool but
it's the very first screen you see the
game right it's a little bit rather it
had gone to this screen but you know
that's just my my slave yeah absolutely
no I think I think it's a really good
point and again beautiful composition
over here on the title screen like this
is this is nice again I'd like to see a
standard Android share icon next to
other things or in place of other things
I really you know people should be
allowed to share on whatever social
network there are they are you know
using and this there again you know
there are places in the world in which
actually Facebook is not the most
popular social networking neither and
Twitter people don't even know about it
so make sure that users that are in
Korea for example for example yeah King
use their social networks social
networks out there they're probably a
lot more beneficial so yeah so you know
just again I using the Android standard
shara kind of lousy use what they have
installed if you want to include things
next to it that's great but i really i
really like seeing at least that there
but let's play this so this is actually
was very interesting because it was one
of those things where it's a beautifully
beautifully drawn game so we're gonna
try a harder level because just more fun
zinc so you're basically controlling a
dragon and your objective is this a
throw breathe fire balls and fiery fury
against all of your opponents and right
now it's these little wizards and
they're keeping your baby dragons
captive either they were known as maybe
they are wizards in a case that so the
thing about so think the animation is
actually really really well done on the
dragon it really it feels almost like
cartoon animation which is great i would
say the only sad thing for me about this
one was that the destruction of the
building was so boring like they're you
know they're not building I don't like
man's from old school yeah it is
basically it is exactly like that what
you get in worms you know you and you
don't get things that are falling any
reason this way you don't get any kind
of destruction it was kind of sad
because everything is so beautifully
done other than that and it was sort of
it was toward us at it doesn't mean the
game isn't fun the game is still fun
it's still beautiful it's just that I
was hoping that I was gonna get this
cool physics game and what I actually
got was sort of a very very old school
old school kind of
and you know when it came to the
gameplay itself it doesn't mean it's not
fun right and let me say that but I just
wanted to see it taken to the next level
especially knowing this was a sequel
that being said the artwork is beautiful
the game really is fun it's got a lot of
created elements it's very well animated
so well thought levels yeah I mean I
thought I overall is good job I think
out of the set right now this may be in
terms of probably execution probably the
best one it's kind of wish that it is it
is the most polished of that land of US
policy in terms of the art style the
look and feel all really really blends
together well all the elements are
really well thought out oh yeah I as far
as far as the most fun games to play
honestly both of the two first games
really fun my favorite game was probably
actually the most probably shuffle is
actually pretty fun tenpin shuffle was
way fun and I like I like the weird you
know gravity breakout game yeah yeah
yeah that was pretty face that was
actually you know actually I she was a
different color scheme it was very dark
very dark maybe that was a very visual
person yeah if you want to impress me
it's all about visual so yeah and I
didn't want to mention this is the first
time I've ever actually done one of
these shows without a hat so you know
this is this is this is not only I oh
not only are we in the beautiful
building 44 arcade or at least were in
front of the building forward before me
for arcade but we also have you noticed
this is setting setting a new new trend
here but yeah and all in all seriousness
uh you know this game this game really
has a lot going for it I just kind of
want to see the developer take it to the
next level because I think it could be
better I am I just kind of wish like you
know when you blow up the buildings like
all those bricks and all that for fall
apart and all that stuff but i guess
like that kind of would affect the level
is I'm because you can't hit the Dragons
baby dragons again yes destroy it so
it's like slow thing but overall ki jab
yes and one other thing I would I mean
this is you know when you look at a
presentation like this you know you put
this in front of you know marketing and
Merchandising people and they're not
going to have any trouble featuring this
in terms of the look and feel they're
going to say oh yes this is the kind
professionalism that people expect when
they click on the feature graphic within
Google Play so I think the one thing I
think this is the one game that did not
have a back button thing
so if you do press the back button oh
but in the beginning music it wasn't
this one it may have opted this one
there was a game where it was in mid
play when if you hit the back one it may
have been this one actually in good pay
and not this one no they were through it
was a play another one weird back button
yeah this one this one this one handles
it pretty well yeah there we go wet
weather widget so you know so one of the
things we like talking about
occasionally here on the show and I'm
going to going to move us back to our
kind of correspondents slide here on the
Friday review is is a kind of the kind
of games we're playing now and one of
the ones that Co brought to my attention
is that we have you know the largest
game ever on on in terms of assets
fighter back so the reason why I was
excited about the team it's called the
bard's tale it's from inxile
entertainment and for all of you that
follow the video game news and you gave
me a nerd out there in Zeller thema it
was founded by Brian Fargo he's actually
interplay founder of interplay founded
the wasteland series and so he
successfully did wasteland 2
kick-started wasteland 2 which probably
brought in one multi million I was hurt
you certainly one of those s full of
what was it was pretty big amount of
money for a crowdfunding campaign
absolutely no he actually did um this
was originally i think it was originally
on iOS and is now ported to android and
it was recently originally on on xbox
rxi i have you back in like 2004 was
everything and then they decided to move
to mobile i think it first was on a
different finally it's now on android
and so now its mobile and so I was like
cool I get to play this wherever I want
whatever so I was on my Nexus 7 and it
was probably the best choice to be
honest because I can definitely tell was
made for the nexus 7 tablet but the
total download asset file size was
monstrous almost 4 gigabytes arena how
8.6 3.7 gigs yeah so you definitely need
Wi-Fi Wi-Fi and if you have it if you
even eight gig nexus said I pretty much
the only thing that's gonna be on your
Nexus 7 but am i okay actually it's okay
because it's probably one I don't have I
don't keep that many games that are on
my tablet or so my tablet that is
probably one of the few games that will
be still on my Nexus 7 yeah anyway yeah
absolutely but you know I hats off to
developers for being for being such an
ambitious game it
her it's completely in its completeness
I would say that you know the thing with
the bars hell is it relies so much on
the musical element of the game the
target blank audio it's hard to bring
the game over without having it in there
but the music is enormous there's just
an enormous amount of audio in this game
and you know so if there was a way to
bring over this game this particular
game without without having to have the
audio it might be it might actually
allow for some more casual gamers to
actually get into the game the problem
is that it's you know it's just the
audio really does provide some of the
absolute best you know experience within
the game like a lot of the UK you can
just get me some of the jokes I mean you
can tell like this is a very well
scripted I mean this is this is an adult
game this is this very very clear humor
is pretty funny its body if you've been
to a Renaissance Faire you very much you
pretty much know what this cake is gonna
be like in fact I heard when I went
listen to the first song again like I
know that I've heard that song at
Renaissance Faire um so uh you know he
definitely has that element in it but
yeah if you know if you've got small
children this is probably not the game
do you don't want to share your tablet
if what your small children what you
have is gay yeah yeah it's definitely
it's ugly game for you and your in your
you know teenage you know friends to
play and or Android other dolts you know
it's definitely got that level of humor
in it but it's very fun it's very very
well done and they did a beautiful job
on on the tiger version for nexus yeah
so it looks beautiful so if you take a
dish to switch over to the tablet really
really I mean we're only playing this on
a transformer and if this is what it
looks like on the transformer you can
imagine and actually there's two
different versions um it does I mean the
basically the basic the actual file
standard file is about 1.6 gigs but if
you do have a nexus 7 or any Tegra 3
often Tegra 3 tablet an nvidia tablet
and then you will be given the option to
download I thicker I just preciate i
thought this song was just so
appropriate our Friday review here right
and yeah you can't actually hear this
song basically sung in its entirety
Renaissance Fairs so but it but in all
seriousness um that's actually so the
transformer prime is the same GPU and
you know st. similar kind of
compatibilities to what we have in the
7 all right but yeah this this does have
like the truly awesome awesome massive
mega down to tape made available for for
for the nvidia chips and it really does
look good as you can see it's just it's
it's really really great to get to see
it so i thought i mentioned cuz
sometimes we don't talk about what we're
playing right and it's a nice day by the
way in addition to all these other games
that we're playing we're also spending
time doing this right so you can tell
yes my range of games that i like are
pretty far hey pretty extreme absolutely
what's why it's great to have co here on
this does pretty pretty much you know
they're through thur games hey I like my
match three games gay guy like Matt
strange absolutely so yeah that's that's
why that that's why it's good to kind of
mix things up here on the frontier if
you get lots and lots of different ideas
and also kind of kind of find out you
know what people are playing so yes tell
us what you're playing make sure to go
to the moderator page nominate your
favorite games nominate games that
you've written nominate you know now
many games that you think we should know
about and like time yeah and even if you
have a game if the game is awesome but
something about it just drives you nuts
let us know because we want to make
games better on android that's that's
art that's our goal here and it's okay
if they're in another language yes
actually speak in recreant so absolutely
and and i can watch her speak and very
create so it all works out so um so I
think we're to have a night a short show
here today on the Friday review so
there's anything else is there anything
from the live stream that we should know
about is there anyone on the live stream
there's tons of people to live stream
but I think you answered the biggest
question which was where's your hat so I
think we wait where's my hat but now
everyone knows why Dan wears a hat but
we got what we coming up we do so we
should do a show about zombies are we
know yes you know have you see some
great halloween themed games out there
let's start getting them you know
nominated if we see enough of them will
do a halloween themed show and we'll
actually dress up so yeah absolutely i
mean what would you dress up as that i
don't know that's a secret maybe that's
a moderator for oh yeah you actually do
a halloween that's right a bad idea bad
idea yeah exactly
Hey oh you dress up however you like and
and we'll see with it with some
anticipation here you know set set some
you know suspense about what what comit
actually dress up as for amateur
episodes all right so that's that's it
for me here us at the Friday review
thank you of course once again to Daniel
Pham for being our engineer today making
sure everything ran smoothly he also
corralled us and made sure the show
happened today so right which is always
good and of course Cheers happy Friday
everybody Friday